The Ukrainian city of
Dnipro is reeling
from a deadly Russian strike
on a medical complex
which killed two people
and injured dozens.
CNN Senior
International correspondent Fred Pleitgen
is in key for us right now Fred.
Ukraine says this was a deliberate
Russian attack once again
on Ukrainian civilians.
What more
are you learning about this
latest strike?
Hi there, Wolf.
What are they saying?
It's it's
a deliberate attack
using missiles
that are normally used
to shoot down aircraft.
They're called the S-300
or S-400 missiles.
And if you use those in a ground
to ground configuration,
the Ukrainians say
they're extremely inaccurate
and they can cause massive carnage
if they're shot at urban areas.
It's exactly what happened today
in the town of Dnipro.
Here's what we're learning
The horrifying aftermath of
another Russian airstrike,
a medical facility
hit in Dnipro, killing
two and wounding scores
as Moscow
launched another round of drone
and missile strikes
at targets across Ukraine.
But Kiev says
this time
they managed to take down
all the cruise missiles
and nearly
all the Iranian supplied charred drones.
CNN got rare access to a key
component of Ukraine's air defense.
The German made Gephardt anti-aircraft
system known as the shithead killer
site that much of time is essential.
Radar operator Olé tells me
there may be three to four targets
and we need to destroy them one by one.
The computer system
makes it as easy as possible
for the gunner to succeed
Ukrainian forces gave us this video
they say shows
a gap are destroying
several Iranian made drones
and this one even shooting down
a cruise missile late last year.
Yes, gunfire.
It's part of Ukraine's
increasingly effective,
mostly Western
supplied, layered, short,
medium and long range air defense
including the US made patriots
that both Washington
and Kiev say have managed
to even take down the feared
Russian tinge.
While hypersonic missiles
that can travel ten times
the speed of sound
and which Putin claimed were invincible.
The commander of
Ukraine's joint forces tells me system
supplied by the U.S.
and its allies
are making all the difference,
as the Kremlin does.
We have the means that can fight tin
gels and ballistic
missiles, as well as cruise
missiles and strike drones, he tells me.
And the percentage
is constantly increasing.
Now, the efficiency is over 80%
from this episode perfectly.
And as Ukraine's army
gears up for a large scale
counteroffensive,
a strong protection
against threats from the skies
will be crucial.
The Ukrainian say
they fully understand that
effective air
defense will be critical
to their upcoming counter offensive
not just to protect
critical infrastructure and ammunition,
but to defend advancing forces as well.
What kind of sea
the enemy will throw all available forces
to reduce the combat
potential of our offensive,
the general tells me.
The success during the advance
and liberation
of Ukrainian territory
will depend on high quality air
defense
and civilian lives on the ground
depend on it as well
to prevent attacks like in Dnipro,
where once again so many were harmed
So more
news happening tonight,
Wolf, from the Russian occupied
city of Mariupol.
Apparently some explosions
going on there.
The authorities there
the Russian installed authorities
there are saying they believe
that it was Ukrainian long
distance rockets hitting targets there.
Of course,
we know Mariupol
right now,
one of the main
staging points for the Russians
for their war in Ukraine.
And of course, we also know
that some believe
that shaping operations
for that Ukrainian offensive
might already be going on Wolf.
Fred Pleitgen reporting from Ukraine.
Stay safe. Fred, thank you very much.
Joining us now to break down these late
breaking developments out there
on the front lines of Ukraine,
CNN military analyst, retired U.S.
Air Force
Colonel Cedric
Leighton, along with former U.S.
ambassador to Ukraine, William Taylor.
Colonel Leighton,
Russia has a proven record
of attacking medical targets,
but is this strike also a reaction
to Ukraine's expected
counteroffensive that's about to begin
It could very well be, Wolf.
And the reason I say that is
they were clearly lobbing
artillery tours to areas
where they think the Ukrainians
are staging their military at.
And Dnipro would be the perfect place
for the Ukrainians to form up
and then move into the south,
particularly to go
after the land bridge
that the Russians have set up
between Crimea and the Donbas.
Ambassador Taylor,
I know you just returned from a meeting
with top Ukrainian officials
in Kiev, the capital.
What are you hearing from them
about their readiness
for this offensive,
this counteroffensive?
Wolf, they are ready.
We talked to the minister of defense
as well as the minister
of foreign affairs, as well as soldiers,
both privates
that are going back out to the front.
Lieutenant, what is General?
They are ready.
They are as you just reported,
they are so pleased that the weapons
that they've gotten,
their ability
to shoot down these missiles,
but also all the armor
that they've gotten in order to
go after this big counter-offensive.
Colonel Leighton,
you just heard and Fred
Pleitgen is report from Kiev
about the success
that Ukraine's
air defenses
have had against these incoming
Russian rockets and missiles.
But as the Netherlands
apparently is now dragging its feet
on officially sending its F-16
fighter jets to Ukraine.
How strong is Ukraine's offensive
offensive capability in the air
Well, it's it's certainly
without the F-16, of course, it's
weaker than it would otherwise be.
But the Ukrainians weren't
going to be getting the F-16 before
this offensive
or even during this offensive.
Their offensive
capabilities are fairly strong
and they have the ability to move
with their tanks.
They have their ability to move
with their armored personnel carriers.
And they also have
the remnants of their air force,
which is really effective
against the Russians.
And then, as Fred pointed out,
the integrated air defense capabilities
that they have are substantial.
And that will make a major difference
because it will protect
the Ukrainian forces as they advance.
Ambassador Taylor,
at this point,
Ukraine has not claimed
responsibility for this latest
explosion in Mariupol.
But are Ukrainian
officials ramping up attacks
on Russian held territory in Ukraine
and Russian soil, for that matter,
as part of its strategy to prepare
for an offensive?
They absolutely are.
They are going after ammo dumps.
They're going after headquarters.
They're going after communications nodes.
They are preparing
for this counteroffensive.
And that means taking out the ability
of the Russians to move and communicate
and command their troops.
Ambassador Taylor, thank you very much.
Colonel Leighton, thanks to you.